what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos and guys
let's get this video to 2,000 likes
that's the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so guys um I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I forgot to tell you that I
was gone the last two weeks I I went to
Miami for some podcasts and Christine
filled in for me like the helpful
helpful chick that she is thank you guys
for your patience I am back and I'm
ready now and guys I think hell has
frozen over while I've been gone I have
seen story after story after Story just
telling me we are in the end of times um
all that stuff in the Bible what they're
talking about in Revelation it's really
going on so I don't know when the AST
roid is going to hit but I am literally
waiting every single day just praying to
God please please please do not let the
asteroid hit today please okay so first
of all Adam 22 Adam calls me a
misogynist you guys remember this beef I
had with Adam me and Adam were fine I
enjoyed going on his show and then he
this summer decides to call me a
misogynist now I take this allegation
very serious iously this is very serious
stuff and I don't take that lightly he
also continued to talk about how I I I
fell off I guess I guess I'm just
falling off and really all of these
guests come on his show to talk [__]
about me so
Adam this is just me pointing out that
the real
misogyny is having your wife sleep with
five men now
Adam 22 loaned his wife out to another
man so he had his wife of like three
months do a porno with another man right
after they got married so Len of the
plug slept with Jason love and they did
a a porno together and really guys um I
think this is an insult to the
institution of marriage I don't
understand why people like this get
married marriage is supposed to be a
religious institution I'm a Catholic and
in the Catholic church we believe it's
till death do you part for richer for
poorer for sickness and in health till
death do you part and people like this
make a mockery of the sacrament of
marriage now Adam 22 has um really
insulted me many times on the internet
and his most recent insult you know I I
half kiddingly asked if his wife wanted
to box me you know cuz I I went I went
boxing in Miami I was like I did my my
first time and I just thought it was
funny and he says that he is going to
box me because apparently I am trans I
didn't know my whole life I didn't know
I was trans I I didn't I've never been
told that I looked like a man before I
came on the internet but
apparently I am just super manly and I
am just a trans apparently you know so
um that's a bit rude that's a bit rude
but you know whatever whatever so
recently
he decided to release a photo of his
wife Lena with five men behind him let's
pull it
up oh my
gosh one guy wasn't enough now we're g
to do not one not two not three not four
but five men I think this is very sad I
think it's very sad I think it's sad
because one day again uh Pearl cares
about the kids here if if you guys
wanted to just be in a relationship and
do this craziness that's fine that's on
you but I think that children have right
and I think it is your responsibility as
a parent to not do things that would
make it difficult for your kid to grow
up and I don't know why they keep
engaging in behavior that one day their
kid is going to have to grow up and see
I think it's wrong and I think it's
selfish so Twitter has had a lot to say
about this now Ryan says bring the
camera guy for your wife's Five Guy meal
is insane yes this is crazy why did you
guys have to get married just be in a
relationship and don't make the kids
suffer yes guys that is making the kids
suffer so I tweeted it is the end of
times yes yes I do think this is the end
of times you know and I will say Adam is
a marketing genius I am sure they are
making a [__] ton off of this now but at
what cost is this worth the price that
you pay I mean your kids's mental health
oh whatever I guess I guess they'll be
fine and you know what we have had an
entire generation of people that said
their kids will be fine my kid will be
fine in a single mother home my kid will
be fine without their dad around my kid
will be fine with me working as a
stripper my kid will be fine with me
working and not being at home and the
truth of the matter is these kids are
not fine we have more mental health
issues in America than we have ever had
in all of history we have kids wake up
and just decide to shoot up a school and
a lot of these issues are linked to a
breakdown in the family unit with
parents that really were were just
selfish where they thought oh I my my
money is more important my feelings are
more important and my career is more
important and really they're trading
their kids mental health for what a
little bit of money a little bit of gold
and speaking of gold are you feeling
unsure about your finances these days
you're really you're not alone guys this
is why noble gold Investments is here to
help just hear it straight from all of
the folks that they have helped the
noble gold crew walked me through
everything no stress and with their help
I can finally sleep easy at night and
now this month Noble gold Investments is
handing out a free 5 o Silver America
the Beautiful coin if you qualify for
the IRA invest in gold and silver with
Noble gold Investments go to noblegold
investments.com now Noble gold
investments.com they are the only gold
company that I trust
now the world is just going to hell the
world just freezing over like I I I
really think this is the end of times
because um not only not only is Adam 22
going mad we have Jada Smith
embarrassing Will Smith now guys a
couple times of a crazy lady one is J
picket Smith not taking Will Smith's
last name a lot of feminists will do the
the two last name thing where it's like
why why don't you want to belong to your
husband why do you want to belong to
yourself and your that doesn't really
doesn't really make sense to me so as
you guys may or may not know Jada has
really embarrassed Will Smith Will Smith
and Jada picket Smith were like the
couple of the century everybody loved
them they talked about how amazing they
were how awesome they were and there
were all these clips in the early 2000s
of them really being put on a pedestal
as a
now guys I remember I had this
conversation with my mother before any
of the entanglement stuff came out I
said there is something wrong in that
family and my mom my mom said no she
said no they're cute whatever I said no
no no something is off something is off
because their kids are messed up because
I saw a video of Willow Smith talking
about how she was in an open
relationship and I remember she was like
18 19 at the time and I thought where
the hell did she get these ideas there's
no way in hell that I would have ever
thought to be in an open relationship I
wouldn't even know what that was and
later it comes out that Will and Jada
were in an open relationship kind of
makes sense but anyways I called this I
called this before anybody now Jada is
basically going on a tour for her new
book and on this tour Jada reveals that
Tupac proposed to her while he was in
jail let's pull it up a lot of people
might not know but he proposed to you
while he was in jail
I talk about this in the book when I go
to see him and Rikers when I wrote about
that in the book and when I had to
um talk about it uh speak my words for
the audible version of the book that was
probably one of the more painful Parts
seeing him
there the condition that he was in and
having to leave him there and um he was
in he was he was in a he was he was he
was in bad shape
and so when he asked me to get married
he was at
Riker's and I knew at that time that a
he needed somebody to do time with him
which I was gonna do anyway you didn't
have to marry me to do that right I'm
I'm here I see why we love
you and then to um like he needed a r
can you imagine being married to a woman
for 20 plus years and she's still
talking about her High School boyfriend
now J alleges they never hooked up or
anything but even if it was just an
emotional thing like J it's been 20 plus
years it's been 20 plus years and it's
so bad to the point that her daughter is
talking about how she misses Tupac and
even Will Smith admitted that at one
point he was jealous of their
relationship can you imagine a man
that's been gone for how long and you
know there's more to this interview so I
wanted to pull pull up another clip he
needed uh because of our friendship and
because of everything we had been
through
together he just
wanted to feel that solidified
Foundation you know cuz I promise you he
would have married me and divorced me as
soon as his ass down he would have all
right I be real with it right cuz so
many people in that position don't have
support right none at all none
you know and right he was just like
look and I just think it was the Mind
state that he was in you know he he
wrote me this long
letter and um I think even before Pac
went to jail he was starting to Trend he
was starting to shift in a certain
manner good or bad
good really good so guys again this is
why men pass up on women that have dated
Bad Boys boys in the past because a lot
of times the men of the future cannot
live up to the drama and excitement they
got out of those toxic relationships now
she claims they never hooked up I doubt
it but let's let's just assume she's
telling the truth and they never hooked
up that means this is the type of guy
that can put a woman in the friend zone
yes those guys do exist and they will
put women in the friend zone now she's
in the position where will the standup
family man will never live up to the
back boy that she never got and she
never could get so if you guys don't
remember last year Will Smith went vir
roll for slapping Chris Rock at the
Oscars Chris Rock made a joke about Jada
and you know will just got super mad and
then went up and slapped him for
it oh
wow wow Will Smith just smacked the [__]
out of me so fast forward to 2023 Jada
picket Smith says she was surprised will
referred to her as wife at the Oscars we
have been separated for 6 years let's
pull it up now first of
all I'm really shocked CU mind you I'm
not there we haven't called each other
husband and wife yeah in a long time I'm
like what is going on right now my name
out of your mouth right and I'm like but
now I'm really worried for will cuz I
don't know what's going
on essentially Will and Jada were going
on all these talk shows talking about
how happily married they were giving
this presentation to the world that they
were happily married and really I would
argue that this is fraud how many people
modeled their relationship after them
not knowing how crazy it really was and
it's funny because in the red pill this
has been known they have known that Jada
was nuts for years they've predicted
this and and there's telltale signs that
that you can really pick up in
relationships to see who's leading it
and typically if the woman's leading it
we just lead things to destruction so
one sign is that the wife doesn't take
the husband's last name um another sign
is that they refer to it as a
partnership they didn't do it there but
that's a common one another one is who
speaks first when the couple is asked a
question who's generally the center of
attention when they're talking to a
couple does the woman feel like she
needs to ask for permission from her
husband to do things go places or make
family decisions and you will see that
Jada and will over the years have
displayed many many of those warning
signs but you really wouldn't know
unless you're in the red pill so let's
pull up this old clip of Jada pull it up
the only person I can give permission is
myself yes exactly yeah the only person
who can give permission to [__] my [__]
is me and will goes yeah so she's your
wife you don't have any control over who
[__] her that's how you view your
relationship will yeah I'm the only one
who tell with [__] to [__] my [__] oh
yeah yeah baby yeah oh yeah someone
rallied your wife for 4 years what's
your issue your childish it all started
with him just needing some help you
notice what she did there she started
the story and she put herself in a
position of moral High Ground not I was
looking for dick we became friends he
needed help so being the great nice
person you can't get mad at her for
helping him that would be terrible he
needed some help and I thought if I give
him a blow job maybe you know how many
people I've helped without [__]
that's what my reply would be cuz I held
the door open for the [__] cameraman
I suck his dick so we can help loads of
people without [__] nobody ho you
know I might have to end this T speech I
don't know how much longer I can do this
yeah baby we
all wanted to help a let me calm
down see okay one I wanted to point out
how Jada says she doesn't need
permission and while this situation was
crazy her sleeping with another dude
that mindset typically translates I
don't need permission from you to tell
me what to wear I don't need permission
from you to tell me what to talk about
or where to go uh that mentality does
not work in relationships it does not
happy wife happy life leads to
destruction I mean look at this
craziness um and Andrew Tate is right he
is absolutely
right Will Smith is a successful
handsome rich guy that is absolutely a
beta so people have asked me for the
definition of a beta and I really I came
to a conclusion betas are men that
follow women yes that follow what women
want while men submit to the authority
of stronger men or to God Bas submit to
the authority of women and unfortunately
even though Will Smith is extremely
talented he is beta I mean I don't know
what is a more beta thing you can do
than loan your wife out I mean that's
that's crazy so the comment section
weighed in Will Smith once seemed like
an example to follow now he's an example
of what to avoid uh another comment says
will is the biggest s in the world um
yos for twizzle says Jada is a walking
bald L Boer prash I thought Will Smith
was a powerful person but TC Libra she's
also the only one who decides who FS
Wills [__]
to
wow
um yeah U yeah and and and this shows
how women ruin Empires the wrong woman
can absolutely not only destroy a guy's
life but destroy a guy's Empire and guys
it is better for men to be alone than to
be with women like this and I don't
remember what verse please Bible people
help me because I don't I don't remember
but there is there is a verse in the
Bible that talks about how a man is
better to be alone than to be with a
quarrelsome wife and if this situation
doesn't show that I don't know what will
Will Smith would be better off alone
than to be in this situation all right
and speaking of feminist terms so guys
I've been in England for about um almost
I think 2 years now and one thing I
noticed when I came to England um so if
you guys don't know I was recruited from
America to the UK to play volleyball and
I play volleyball here in England and
when I first got here one thing I
noticed was how much more prevalent the
word partner is than husband or
boyfriend or girlfriend and this just
like blew my mind every show so I do
wish I used to do a show four days a
week on relationships and every show I
would come out and we would talk about
all this all these different things in
relationships and even married women
would call their husband's partner and
Rolf Degan on Twitter recently put out a
study that said in the past decade
partner has overtaken the term boyfriend
and girlfriend on Twitter for one
significant other so again husband
implies that you submit to their
Authority partner implies that you are
equal and this shows just how deep
feminist language is in our culture
because language shapes behaviors and
behaviors shape language it goes both
ways I don't actually know which way it
goes does Behavior shape language or
just language shaped Behavior but I mean
they impact each other I don't really
think this is disputed and the fact that
the culture is now referring to husband
and wife as equal the same really
implies that men don't Authority in
their own household so some individuals
have chosen to adopt the gender neutral
term partner to refer to their romantic
counterpart in place of the gender terms
boyfriend and girlfriend in the past
partner was used by individuals within
the
lgbtq plus Community to describe their
romantic interest however here we
explore this linguistic Trend with data
from millions of individual
self-descriptions and US Twitter users
profile bials from 2012 to 2023 we found
increased use of partner coinci sident
with decreased use of boyfriend and
girlfriend wow I wonder what happened in
2013 it looks like there's like a steep
drop like what happened in 2013 guys let
me know what you think in the comments I
don't even know but I I would say this
is a problem and until we start
implementing policies and creating
societal change that really implies that
men are the head of the household and we
should submit to men's authorities I
don't see this changing and it's really
sad because I really think you're going
to keep seeing the breakdown of the
family and you're going to keep seeing
that it's going to get harder and harder
to get into relationships if this trend
continues so um another Trend we've
talked about on the show I mean how many
times is that women are getting more and
more entitled and the problem we're
going to have in 2023 is if as the price
of women gets higher and higher you're
going to see less men wanting to buy and
sign up for marriage and relationships
unfortunately after a certain Point men
are going to look and just say the juice
is not worth the squeeze so there is a
woman that is going viral because she
wanted 15,000 for a holiday let's pull
it
up buy his stuff even the holidays that
he's mentioning is even still a problem
what about because when I ask him for
holidays it's not like he even still
wants to provide as well listen this
woman wants me to give her £15,000 for
her to go on a 4- day trip to Miami oh
okay the cost of living is just stupid
these days and she wants me to give 15
grand so you go go go was you already
know how I live my life I haven't lost
my
mind 15
grand okay guys let's just be objective
can we pull up pull up pull her up again
I want to see if we should raid her one
to 10 King what would you what would you
raate her one to 10 what would you rate
her one to 10 okay that's what I would
say to you okay so we have a chick
that's maybe slightly above average
she's what a six six five six I mean who
knows under all that makeup we don't
even know what she looks like um and
she's demanding I mean honestly I would
say that's like nine prices guys look
think about it this way when you have
men spending a bunch of money on women
when you have I I honestly I've thought
about this and I'm playing around with
this idea but you guys can tell me what
you think I think that women should
spend money on men yes yes okay hear me
out hear me out I think women are in
their true femininity it's not really
about money it's not really about soft
life if you look back I want you guys to
Google a day in the life of the Amish
these women get up at like 6:00 a.m. to
milk the cows they tow the fields they
help their husbands like true femininity
is not it's not the soft Life wearing a
pretty dress no true femininity is
serving the
men yes yes guys I was thinking about
this I'm like when men are spending all
this money on women really they're
serving the women so I actually think
I'm G to get so much hate for this
opinion but I actually think it makes
more sense for women to serve the men if
you guys didn't know this chivalry is
actually gynocentric so again I believe
that gynocentrism is basically women
good men bad and really gynocentrism
disrupts the natural order of the world
and I think the natural order is God men
women children and the women have to
serve the men and shivalry started
basically a thousand years ago so years
ago proposals and just romantic love
really started and it used to be that
men would submit to the authority of
stronger men and stronger men would
submit to the authority of God and it
used to be that men would bow down to
the king and they would Kneel To The
King and a proposal actually switches it
where the woman is in the place of the
king so think about that guys what does
that do that implies that the woman is
above the man chivalry is generally seen
as a good thing by the right and the
left it's generally seen as what we are
supposed to do the good old days I would
argue gu I'm sorry guys I'm sorry I
don't want to ruin this for you but I
would argue it's not I would argue it is
not a good thing and the reason being is
because it disrupts the natural order of
the world and puts the woman above the
man why does the woman deserve the man's
hard-earned
money why what has she done to earn it
now I also hear the argument that men
are supposed to protect and provide and
that's why they should pay on dates I
question this narrative because
typically the protection and
provisioning historically romantic love
wasn't really a big thing and the
protection and provisioning was given in
exchange for children and actually women
in a lot of countries came with a dowy
so women would actually spend money
first I mean it would come from their
dads but you guys see the idea it was
he's offering the protection and
provisioning for a lifetime and it was
seen he was seen as the pride he was
seen as far more valuable than her and
he was given money to take care of her
for a lifetime so I I haven't I'm not
definitive on this topic okay I I could
go both ways but I'd love to hear you
guys's argument in the comment section
because I think there's a solid argument
that could be made for women needing to
spend money on men okay J production
said why would you even entertain a
woman like that weak man I agree um
amaris this woman has stand standards
and oh no why God this woman has
standards and understands her worth
really okay I a man want to be a man
until we ask for something then they
really bring nothing to the table 15
grand oh my
gosh oh my gosh what a this is madness
madness so there I watched a documentary
this morning actually I watched it on a
day in the life of the Amish and there's
actually a community of the Amish that
it's literally like going back in time
because they have no contact with the
outside world like there's some Amish
that kind of are like half in half out
it was so interesting listening to the
women because the women knew that their
job was to serve the men and you you had
none of this entitlement [__] it was
literally like going back in time and
now you have women asking for cash and
they might as well ask for gold because
gold won't
lose value to
inflation um so you want to take control
of your future finances and don't know
where to start Noble gold Investments
understands investing in Precious Metals
may sound confusing but the team at
Noble gold makes it easy let's hear from
actual Noble gold investment customers
the staff answered all of my questions
and help me every step of the way no
pressure sales tactics just honest
guidance securing my future is less
stressful thanks to Noble Gold's
expertise so don't settle for financial
uncertainty they'll suggest options and
see if you can diversify into gold and
silver right now Noble gold Investments
is offering a free 5 oce America the
Beautiful bullan coin for qualified
accounts don't settle for financial
uncertainty Noble gold Investments has
an A+ rating with the Better Business
Peru and countless festar reviews why
wait go to noblegold investments.com now
that's noblegold investments.com the
only gold company that I trust okay so
um as you guys know I've talked a lot
about majestic creatures on this channel
for those of you that know that know fat
chicks now fat chicks really get
sensitive when we talk about their
weight and the truth is that men prefer
thinner healthy women and typically what
you see from bigger women is that they
get mad and they they just [__] on me
for this opinion but recently an
overweight woman has come out to give
her opinion on fat jokes let's pull it
up okay let's be real if you can't
handle the fat jok lose the weight okay
I'm
say BBL
sponsor oh wait actually I think that
was a dude I don't know I just I saw the
clip but seriously guys and I actually
love this because it's so much better
when you could just poke on yourself I'm
not saying to bully people into Oblivion
but I mean come on guys I'll take a
ginger joke you know what I mean you
can't get that big and not be able to
take a fat joke here or there and we've
sort of lost this ability in America
like like I remember when I was a kid
early 2000s I mean it was more common to
see racist sexist and homophobic jokes
let's you say but as women have entered
the media and the workforce you really
see that going away way because and it's
interesting that this is a dude like
actually that's saying that because men
are better able to take being made fun
of we're women we just we just don't
really do it well and my plea to women
is if you want to be in a man's world if
you want to be on the internet if you
want to be in the media if you want to
do all this stuff then be in it be in it
don't cry and complain about being made
fun of later when you asked to be in a
guy's world that you didn't have to be
in and that's why you see this
phenomenon when women enter space like
politics media and corporations you see
this phenomenon of people policing
speech Human Resources lawsuits Etc when
at the end of the day we cannot police
speech we can't and again I say if you
want to be in a man's world be in it
okay so um so last but not least today I
want to talk about Bella porsch so Bella
porsch is a viral Tik Tok star this
woman so I remember early Tik Tok days
when Bella blew up so this woman had the
most viral Tik Tok of all time the most
viewed video with over 50 million views
and it was so interesting to just see
her face like she found a way to make
her face like move with the m it was
kind of cool and recently I saw a video
of her on call her daddy talking about
how her career actually led her to
divorce let's pull it
up I want to be an artist I want to sing
I want to be like I want to be in the
spotlight like I want to form and um I
don't think he ever wants to be part of
that sometimes it just it just sucks cuz
you know like you want to do something
for yourself and like a career but then
you love someone and they they can't
handle it so it's just like you kind of
just have to pick right so words are
important and I wanted to point out
something that she says during this
video that you kind of just have to pick
and you know she goes on I watch this
whole interview she actually goes on to
talk about how he was a really private
person and her becoming a public figure
really just damaged their relationship
and they couldn't handle it and again
you'll you'll see this tendency for
women to and I hear older women talk
about this too I just want to do
something for myself and it's funny
because when men do selfless things
they're a lot less narcissistic with it
and they don't look at it as a burden
they look at it as a duty where when
women tend to do things like for the
family
they look at it as a detriment they they
hold resentment to the people that hold
back their decision now I will say this
decision may work out for her she may
end up getting remarried she may be able
to have it all but there are thousands
of women that watch these type of videos
and think they will have the same
outcome as a woman that is worth
millions and millions of dollars that is
born one of the most I I would argue top
20ish per of Beauty most women will not
have these outcomes for making selfish
decisions and typically women and her
shoes don't end up having good outcomes
anyway but I just I want to give the
devil's advocate here and here this
woman says she's speaking for so many
women here she is and that's the sad
part she absolutely is speaking for many
women because many most women are
selfish in 2023 most women care more
about them eles and their career than
their family and children and she admits
it there that her career was more
important and she was going to pick
herself and I don't I don't really I'm a
little bit I have a nuanced opinion on
this stuff do what you're going to do at
least she didn't have children okay but
don't complain later don't whine and cry
about the outcomes later you're a man if
he really loves you he'll support you no
matter what oh really what if she wants
to do sex work what if she's putting
their relationship in a compromising
position no matter what really really
and this is this feminist garbage that
we've just been programmed that's been
shoved down our throat that says we can
do everything a man can do and still
have it all the truth of the matter is
everything in life comes with choices
and trade-offs you cannot have
everything Juna pup says she chose her
dreams he can't just be proud of what
she has accomplished right now well at
what cost is the question and you don't
know the ins and outs of the story you
don't know his side of things maybe she
was going out and putting their
relationship in compromising positions
maybe he's a private person and didn't
sign up to be a part of that life and
the thing is women will constantly lead
other women down the path of Destruction
so now you know the question becomes is
the grass greener on the other side for
Bella I really I hope it is I never wish
negativity on people but I will say in
most cases it's not um Bella porch is
talking about here splitting the bill on
a recent date let's pull it
up have you gone on any dates like
what's the vibe yeah um okay actually
went on a date a few days ago how'd it
go it was weird cuz I he likes me but we
split the
bill it's interesting because women want
to be modern when it benefits them but
traditional when it doesn't I'm sorry
but why is this girl worth millions and
millions of dollars complaining about
splitting the bill I I mean you know you
wanted to be modern which is fine no
hate but don't complain about the
outcomes later and these guys are
probably thinking this girl's worth I
don't know what she's worth it's but I
would guess upwards of 10 million um
especially what they were paying for Tik
Tok brand deals back in the DI guys it
was stupid it was crazy these these
people were making so much money I
actually I met a bunch of the top like
ticktockers back then oh my God it it
was so crazy I met the demilios back in
the day which is like another top Tik
Tock family and it it was just briefly
but it was so crazy to me to see these
like 18-year-old kids you know driving
sports cars having private drivers going
out to these super expensive meal very
in very cool actually you know it's like
they want to be you can't have
everything you want to be modern you
know take what comes with it and I think
that's actually the trend we're going to
see in the west because you'll see it in
Japan it's actually super normal split
the bills there like it it's like not I
I've asked people over there and they
say it's like very normal the women
don't even think much of it I think
that's a trend you're going to see here
because again you know the price of
women is going up and men are kind of
getting sick and tired of paying for
something they don't really get any
value out of so user 85 says you're not
supposed to split the bill hey Nia don't
date him again LOL red flag sh boy um
this is the etiquette listen up whoever
asks for the date should pay um and I
used to I used to actually have
different views on this like I think um
a couple years ago I used to say that
like men should pay and I I I my issue
with that logic is like we can't have
everything either want to be modern or
we want to be traditional and the
question is if you know paying is a deal
breaker for you are are you the
traditional chick that deserves to be
paid for but to be fair I think most
guys to be honest pay anyway like there
just you know most guys don't really
fight it like that